extraterrestrial monsters time travel
and one very long day Edge of Tomorrow
has a deceptively complex story and an
even more complicated ending here's what
it all means
understanding the ending of Edge of
Tomorrow requires you to pay pretty
close attention from the beginning
because what the mimics are doing gets
explained pretty early on and it goes by
fast according to Dr Carter a mimic
biologist the mimics are really like one
giant interconnected organism the larger
Alpha mimics act as the central nervous
system and command the mimic drones
these high-ranking Alphas then return
information to be processed by the
central
Omega mimic each time an alpha dies the
Omega rolls the clock back 24 hours
keeping all of their Collective
knowledge intact and enabling the mimics
to adjust their strategies in order to
gain a definitive Victory while the
alphas seem to be the decision makers of
the mimics dictating the actions of the
drones and determining their strategy
Carter hypothesizes that since the Omega
essentially functions as the brain of
the mimics the only way to stop the
invasion is to destroy it the problem is
that thanks to their powers the mimics
know about the military's biggest
weakness and they have a lot more
experience than cage and vertasky in
using their time Loop abilities to their
advantage so they're pretty Adept at
keeping the Omega safe and hidden
there's a whole juicy prequel just
waiting to be made in the story of Rita
vertesky and the Battle of Verdun which
we hear about in bits and pieces but
never see from what we learn at the
beginning of the film The Human battle
against the mimics dragged on for five
years before the United Defense Force
finally claimed their first Victory the
offensive was led by Sergeant vertesky
who was later nicknamed the angel of
Verdun the popular version of the story
is that Rita led the UDF troops to
Victory due to her abilities as an
exceptional Soldier but the truth is she
had another advantage that no one knew
about she was living in a Time Loop the
first time bratasky fought the Battle of
Verdun she was killed but similar to
what would later happen to cage when
Rita died she also managed to take an
alpha with her and their blood mingled
together as they both died but instead
of staying dead Rita woke up a day
before Verdun she lived out that battle
over and over gaining a bit more ground
each time before she died after several
resets Rita started experiencing visions
of the Omega and she attempted to
interpret them in order to destroy the
brain and defeat the mimics once and for
all but in the course of finally leading
the UDF to victory over the mimics she
was badly injured and received a blood
transfusion without the mimic blood she
lost both the looping ability and the
visions
the first time cage was dropped into the
middle of the battle in France he had no
idea what he was doing he didn't even
know how to turn off the safety on his
gun yet he managed to survive through
sheer luck however cage eventually wound
up alone and on his back surrounded by
mimics including a giant blue-tinged
Alpha in desperation cage grabbed for a
UDF incendiary device lying beside him
on the ground and fired it off right as
the alpha lunged for him while the
resulting explosion was powerful enough
to blow up the alpha it killed him as
well as cage died the blood of the alpha
dripped into his open wounds passing
along its link to the Omega and giving
cage the same time traveling ability the
alphas have as with the alphas his
Consciousness was knocked back 24 hours
in time since the invasion had taken
place in the morning he woke up on the
preceding morning when he first arrived
at the Heathrow military base when you
kill that Alpha you inadvertently
entered the enemy's nervous system
once cage and bratasky start working
together Rita preps cage for what to
expect he'll keep looping over and over
and eventually start experiencing
visions of the Omega when that happens
the two of them can use Cage's Visions
to locate the Omega and destroy it when
Cage's visions do start he's able to use
architectural Clues to narrow the
omega's location to a dam in Germany
Cajun potaski spend countless Loops
attempting to get from the beach in
France to the dam in Germany but once
cage finally reaches his destination
he's horrified to realize the Omega
isn't there after all it turns out that
his Visions weren't a glimpse into the
omega's Consciousness but rather a
carefully laid trap the Omega showed him
exactly what it wanted him to see cage
is greeted by an alpha and a drone with
the Omega nowhere to be found while
previous mimics have killed cage the
instant they get a chance these mimics
seem to have something else in mind
instead of ripping him apart the alpha
wounds cage giving him a deep gash that
bleeds profusely cage realizes that this
is the mimic's true plan to lure him
away from his allies and then steal back
the power kept in his blood although the
visions of the dam in Germany proved to
be a red herring the Omega was still
hunkered down in Europe just in a
different country after Cajun vatasky
stopped relying on his Visions to lead
them where they needed to go they
managed to locate the Omega through a
different method using the direct link
between the Omega and Alphas to pinpoint
its location
ultimately the real Omega is located
deep beneath the Louvre in Paris France
when cage vertasky and the Rogue J Squad
arrive at the famous Museum they
discover that the area is flooded by the
same river with the Omega located
underwater the entire region is in
disarray following the mimic attacks on
Paris and the resulting floods
so while normally there's no water
underneath the Louvre in this decimated
world cage has to swim the final
distance down to the Omega
after realizing that the Visions are not
a road map to the mimic's greatest
weakness Cajun vatasky are forced to
reevaluate their strategy to destroy the
Omega they decide instead to resort to a
piece of technology Carter started
developing when Rita was the one caught
in the loop Carter was never able to
complete this transponder since for
taskey lost the ability to loot before
they could test it on her and Carter
subsequently lost his job and had his
research confiscated by the UDF after
getting fired it appeared that Carter
tried making a new transponder but he
told vertaski it didn't work so instead
they had to acquire Carter's original
device which was kept in a safe and
general Brigham's office while the
mechanics of the transponder are left a
bit fuzzy it works by making contact
with the blood of an alpha through which
it establishes a link to the Omega and
determines the creature's location since
Cage's blood has the same properties as
that of an alpha britasky was able to
use the transponder on cage which is how
they determined that the Omega is in
Paris
according to vertaski the Only Rule cage
must abide by while he Loops is that if
he's injured he has to make sure he dies
this is the Only Rule
you get injured on the field you better
make sure you die she tells him that the
way she lost the looping ability was
through a blood transfusion causing her
to conclude that blood is the key to the
ability it's never clear exactly how
much blood cage could afford to lose
while still holding on to his ability to
reset based on his other injuries
throughout the film he could definitely
spare at least a pint or two without
risking his link with the Omega and it's
unlikely that a transfusion would have
replaced every drop so it seems most
likely that while some of the Alpha's
blood would remain in his body a
transfusion would dilute it to the point
where the mimic link was severed
after receiving a blood transfusion
following his theft of Dr Carter's
transponder from General Brigham's
office Cajun potaski realized they're
all out of resets that evening is their
very last chance to find the Omega and
prevent the UDF invasion in France The
Invasion is in reality a trap set by the
mimics that will result in the ultimate
and absolute defeat of humanity knowing
they won't get another opportunity they
enlist the help of J-Squad they fly to
Paris where the area around the Louvre
is completely overrun with mimics and
all of J-Squad winds up sacrificing
themselves in their quest to get caged
in for tasky inside once they finally
made it in vertaski offers to provide a
distraction that will allow cage to
cover the remaining distance to the
Omega they both know that neither one of
them has any hope of making it out alive
as an alpha kills for tasky cage gets to
the edge of the water covering the Omega
and begins to swim down to it holding a
belt of grenades the alpha follows him
and stabs him through the chest but
before cage dies he pulls the pins of
the grenades and drops them down to the
Omega as the Omega dies it attempts to
restart the day again but it would seem
that the Omega can't reset itself and
instead of giving the mimics a do-over
it transmits its own death back 24 hours
this has the effect of killing all of
the mimics a day before the Omega itself
was killed
throughout the movie Cajun for taskey
know that if he receives a blood
transfusion he'll lose the reset ability
which is why they ensure that he dies
each time they don't complete their goal
so when he and Rita get into a car
accident following their theft of the
transponder from Brigham's office and
cage is given a transfusion they both
realize they're on their last life but
after the destruction of the Omega cage
wakes up again apparently cage held on
to life just long enough to get bathed
in the omega's blood when the grenades
went off giving him the reset ability
again having that blood in his system
when he died meant that when the Omega
attempted to reset the day cage was
reset too however unlike the mimics
Cage's life wasn't dependent on the
Omega so while the omega's attempted
reset resulted in the deaths of all
mimics cage wasn't affected and got one
last life by the end of Edge of Tomorrow
we've seen cage reset countless times
always at Heathrow military base on the
morning before The Invasion but at the
end of the film cage wakes up in a
helicopter on his way to his meeting
with Brigham before he was ever sent to
Heathrow the different reset points can
be confusing after watching cage always
return to the same time previously but
it makes sense as long as you understand
that cage lost the reset ability before
the end and then regained it the first
time cage died he reset 24 hours into
the past at Heathrow the morning before
The Invasion think of that moment in
time at Heathrow as a video game save
point every subsequent time cage died no
matter how much time passed between his
waking up and that particular death he
always reverted to that Original Point
extending the video game analogy when he
lost the reset ability the saved game
was deleted so the second time he gained
the mimic ability he had to spin up a
new game this established its own unique
save point 24 hours before he killed the
Omega since the Omega died in the early
hours of the morning before the France
Invasion cage reset to the previous
morning right before he met with Brigham
earlier than his arrival at Heathrow
it would be easy to finish Edge of
Tomorrow wondering if cage still has the
ability to reset again if he died since
that's what he does after defeating the
Omega of course without the mimics to
fight cage hopefully wouldn't find
himself facing death every day but it
could still be a handy ability to have
in case he were to for example
accidentally get himself run over by
another truck
however there's no need to speculate
about Cage's power since Chances Are by
the end of the film he doesn't have it
anymore the way that Dr Carter explains
the mimic's ability to cage is that when
an alpha dies the Omega resets it back
to the day before the alpha isn't
resetting itself and it seems to have no
special abilities without the guidance
of the Omega since cage essentially
stepped into the role of an alpha when
he died the time looping isn't his power
without an Omega around the fleeing
Cage's Consciousness back in time
whenever he dies cage is fated to live
and die with no repeat just like the
rest of us
[Music]
foreign
[Music]